so und jetzt reden wir mal über corona
profiteure das geschäft mit online
glücksspiel brummt dank lockdown während
echte casinos und spielhallen zu haben
ist ja klar
hängen die zocker immer länger zu hause
vor ihrem screen online casinos haben
also könnte man sagen eine glückssträhne
und jetzt kommt es ab dem ersten juli
sind sie in deutschland auch noch legal
glückwunsch ja ab dem ersten juli gilt
ein neuer staatsvertrag der sie aus der
schmuddelecke raus holt und das wirklich
geniales timing neulich erst hat ein
deutsches gericht entschieden dass ein
spieler sein bei denen verlorenes geld
zurückkriegt weil illegal
jetzt hilft die politik und legalisiert
die was macht online spielen eigentlich
so verlockend sie müssen nirgendwo
hingehen sie müssen sich nicht wie wenn
sie ins casino gehen vielleicht sogar
noch ein bisschen schick machen
sie können im bademantel unter
drogeneinfluss oder im schlafanzug
betrunken rund um die uhr spielen was
sorry hab grad nicht zuhört ja man kann
24 stunden zocken ohne jede soziale
kontrolle und per mausklick sein geld
verballern in schleswig holstein ist das
schon seit zehn jahren legal und es war
wohl nicht zuletzt unser alter freund
wolfgang kubicki er sich für die
bundesweite legalisierung eingesetzt hat
stark gemacht
experten schätzen rund eine halbe
million deutsche sind spielsüchtig warum
wollen die bundesländer das trotzdem
legalisieren
befürworter des neuen
glücksspielstaatsvertrages verweisen auf
einen angeblichen natürlichen spieltrieb
des menschen der müsse in einen legalen
markt kanalisiert werden
ja musste unbedingt der natürliche
spieltrieb ganz klar darf ich dazu
vielleicht mal was klarstellen
nehmen wir das beispiel mal katzen
katzen haben auch einen natürlichen
spieltrieb voll süß logisch was katzen
aber nie machen sie verzocken nicht am
tablet haus und hof und lassen am ende
ihr katzenklo verwahrlosen also außer
einzelnen katzen spieltrieb und wegen
spieltrieb der staat möchte mitverdienen
schon jetzt nimmt er hier mit
glücksspiel steuern deutlich mehr ein
als zb mit alkohol über 5 milliarden im
jahr
wir belohnen eine branche die in der
illegalität fakten geschaffen hat mit
legalität verschickt das ist so als ob
sie ständig leute mit 100 vor dem
kindergarten blitzen und als konsequenz
dann die tempo 30 schilder abbauen
übrigens wer auch mit verdient sind
diese influenza zum beispiel bei fitch
die stream ihr zocken und animieren so
die fans zum geld verbrennen ist das
denn seriös deswegen würden wir das
wieder zurückgehen während der fischer
ist da ja ein glück dass ja da ist da
fällt mir ein genauso erfrischend
müssten wir hier beim staatsfernsehen
unser online casino aber auch mal
moderieren und verkaufen ja wir haben
doch ein eigenes online casino hier also
lotto-toto kuba das dreht sich ich werd
bekloppt leute cool wenn ich das dreht
was ist es was ist es habe ein loch im
kopf ich bin so gespannt
es ist die 21 die 21 tage hat nämlich
gerechnet und jetzt dreht sich das
weiter und das dreht sich es
funktioniert nicht es passt einfach
nicht zum öffentlich rechtlichen
ich meine klar online gaming war schon
vor corona geradezu ideal für leute die
gerne in ihrem zimmer bleiben aber es
richtet gesellschaftlichen schaden an
die therapien für spielsüchtige zahlen
ja darf man nie vergessen die
krankenkassen und nicht die casinos also
die verursacher immerhin bei denen
demnächst legalen gibt es einen verlust
limit von 1000 euro im monat
viel zu viel sagen experten war es viel
zu wenig zb bei schwarz
sagen die lobbyisten und lobby ihren
fröhlich weiter dabei kamen die
bundesländer den sportwetten anbietern
im letzten september schon mit einer
enormen erhöhung des limits entgegen
besonders vermögende spieler dürfen im
monat bis zu 30.000 euro setzen
ja aber nur vermögende spieler und
vermögen bleibt man so ja nicht lange
erfahrungsgemäß die legalisierung führt
zu noch mehr konkurrenz auf dem markt
denn die illegalen machen ja auch weiter
und werden jetzt natürlich noch
aggressiver um ihre kunden werben
ab dem ersten juli also legale online
casinos in deutschland das kann aber nur
ein anfang sein
deutschland macht endlich alles legal
einbrecher früher hatten sie ein
schlechtes image heute ist einbrecher
ein von der industrie und handelskammer
anerkannter lehrberuf zusammengeschlagen
werden ist nicht schön aber gut wenn es
wenigstens ein fachmann macht der
staatlich lizenzierte körperverletzung
und hier gründet sich heute der lobby
verband deutscher kleindealer leute das
hier dass es unser window of opportunity
die glückspilze sind in den jet gewonnen
mit exakt den argumenten die wir kiffer
schon seit 1000 jahren predigen mit
legalen gras kann deutschland den
natürlichen auftrieb in der politik und
polizei und justiz entlasten aber dass
der dealer verdienen ein arsch voll geld
oder für den bau zu wandern
hier als lobbyverband müssen hier die
extra meilinger und wir brauchen
dringend ein seriöses image kannst du
bitte mal die bauern weglegen kleines
bisschen konzentrationen ja freunde
unser prior on topic ist ab jetzt
networking heißt wir machen es exakt so
wie diese spieler heim ist bin ich du
mir sagst ein paar wissenschaftler die
behaupten dass kiffen hab jetzt gut fürs
herz
sascha du trifft sich heute noch mit
wolfgang kubicki zum land und gibt ihm
diese kleine parteispende unterwegs
lässt mich raus haben einen termin mit
peter altmaier
dafür bin ich schon viel zu spät dran
also los aufgezwungen wenn alles gut
läuft dann schreiben wir kiefer heute
noch die geschichte
mehr silbereisen das mit abstand der
beste kapitän des traumschiffs alle
wollten wir heute nicht irgendwohin
deutschland macht endlich alles legal
außer kiefer denn dienen kann man nicht
helfen
[Musik]
so aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische and cut
von oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reich